you know what i want to know
i want to know where that energy's at
that's what i want to know
you know i live in the south
i live in texas
you know i live in a state where they're
gonna well they passed the ten thousand
dollar snitch law
that's right
they said you know what you know anybody
that goes and gets an abortion
you tell us we you snitch them out we'll
pay you ten thousand dollars
you know
you got
lawmakers willing to make all kinds of
time restrictions
you know only
at you know before six weeks only you
know before this before that after that
it's you know we're going to charge you
with murder we're going to charge the
doctor with murder we're going to charge
whoever gave you a ride with murder
we're going to charge anybody and
everybody hell man your brother-in-law
you had a conversation with him on the
way down to the clinic hell we'll charge
him with murder you know you got all
kinds of energy you know i live in the
south i live in the south i drive by
your churches
and i see the little
crosses sitting out front
i see that
little cross is sitting out front for
all the aborted babies
all the little babies that didn't make
it
well you really care about them
where's that same energy huh
where are the
crosses
for all the people that are killed in
these shootings
all the kids
where are the crosses for the sandy hook
kids where are the
crosses for the goddamn uvalde kids
people shot the shot in in the mall or
wherever you don't give a [ __ ]
because you're not really christians
you aren't
you're
satan worshiping sons of [ __ ] is what
you are
they said they said evil would come
wrapped in a flag and carrying a bible
and i guarantee you you're it
you're it
you're that [ __ ] fascism and evil
it's you
you pretend christians
where are your goddamn crosses for these
people
where are they
how many of them got to die
i guarantee you right now i know what
you're doing you say they ain't taking
my guns not doing it
no
i'm not giving up my assault rifle i'm i
need to fight off the government
[ __ ]
it's [ __ ]
you're fake when you talk about abortion
you don't give a sh
it's about your cult's power
that's what it's about
if you really cared there would be
little crosses all over the goddamn
south for every one of these shooting
victims
but you don't even think about it
never once have i seen a sign for that
but i guarantee you i can drive 10
minutes down the road and there'll be a
church that's got the goddamn little
crosses talking about there's this many
abortions today
oh my blessed god
you people
[ __ ] every last one of you
yep
texas paul thank you for the commentary
and
i understand your passion because i have
the same passion welcome to the
stuttering john podcast
on another somber day in the united
states of america
while ted cruz and governor greg gnabbit
are doing
speeches at the nra convention and yes
that same convention
that banned guns
the hypocrisy never ends with the
republican party people
don't even i'm not shocked anymore you
can't be anymore
the hypocrisy
never ends
and it never will end
why
because
they don't want to do anything
they have no desire to do anything
you think ted cruz really gives a [ __ ]
nah
sure his kids are safe going some
private school somewhere
you don't give a [ __ ]
you think greg abbott gives a [ __ ]
no
you don't give a [ __ ]
marco rubio
now he's speaking too
yeah
does he give a [ __ ] no he doesn't
don't even think he does because he
doesn't
today they had protests
or
two days ago protests all over the place
kids walking out of school
there are children afraid to go
to school
now
i'm older i never had that fear
i i just never did
we don't know the fear that these
children have now
and those kids
who experience this who witnessed this
i hate to say it but they're going to be
the same
this is ptsd
information gathered
by a nine-year-old's eyes
i just i can't believe it
i have children a lot of you here have
children
i just can't believe
that they continue to do nothing
ted
lose
rafael cruz
makes a speech saying i swear to you
we need to go to church more
we need to stop playing video games and
go to church more
really
go to church more ted
is that what makes you leave
texas when your people are freezing
to flee to cancun
go to church more
give me a [ __ ] break ted
you're a slimy piece of [ __ ]
and texas
i ask you
vote of a better or rock
get ted
get
abbott the [ __ ] out of there
get ted cruz the hell out of there
rand paul is he there too let's forget
john corn in it whoever get him out
mark p
marco v i'm doing a beer in the balcony
with my old uh producer at two o'clock
but i i don't want to sorry i'm not
doing the roll call i do want to welcome
andrea brauer
there's a link if you want to donate
paypal dot me slash john melendez inc
sorry i'm not doing the whole kind of
roll call today but i got dean of
obadala waiting
straight off of an article that he just
wrote for
msnbc yeah i do want to thank texas paul
that was texas paul he's on the minus
brothers
um
on their network
and uh you know i just discovered that
guy so
i didn't even know about him kate
friedman
thanks for the first super chat on super
chat saturday
it always comes in handy and now without
further ado
lawyer
author
comedian
writer and damn cute son of a victim
welcome dean obadala good program thank
you my friend that's the nicest intro
i've ever had i really appreciate it my
friend how are you what's going on i i
uh well i'm probably the same as you
right now dean it's
it's just
you know it's i thought sandy hook that
was that was gonna be enough but no
it still happens and you know
this is one point that i want to make
that
and then you know then i'm gonna talk to
you about your article and everything
now yes those cops are idiots i mean
they didn't go in when they had the
chance
which which is lunacy to me when kids
are calling 9-1-1 there's no
communication with nine-on-one the cops
are still waiting because they think
they're barricaded whole bunch of
horseshit
where is john mclean where is you know
where is someone with common sense to go
in there and take this [ __ ] out
now mm-hmm issued dean as much as it is
with those police i don't want see this
is what's gonna happen here now dean
everyone's gonna shift the focus
right on to blaming the police
and not blaming the people
our elected officials who have been
doing nothing about this for 20 years
what say you missed
oba darwin i agree with you john i i
think there are two different issues
though and i think that we should make
them separate so that we come back to
the the key issue which is preventing
these kind of horrific acts and murders
in the future we just had a terrorist
attack a week ago in buffalo and that's
easy access to
weapons of war so that's one issue the
police issue is at first i didn't want
to even talk about it because i'm like
this is a distraction then after
yesterday's press conference it became
very real the fact that 84 minutes of
terror for these children who were
sitting there in that room and we know
now there were within two minutes
the gunman enters 11 33 by 11 35 their
time in the morning three officers
arrived three and he shoots at them and
they just retreat and hide and that's it
if they would have kept coming they
could have clearly saved numerous lives
we're talking about because that was two
minutes in and then seven officers are
there within a few minutes after that
and then of course what you're getting
at the horrific and i was actually
so overcome by emotion i was
crying on my show last night and expect
to
talking about the 911 calls these
children begging for their lives sitting
there on their cell phones eight and
nine-year-olds saying
please send in the police
and talk about there's at least eight of
us are still alive meaning these little
kids are aware that others have been
their heads blown off because they are
15 it goes in like a bullet hole and the
exit wounds the size of a grapefruit if
not even bigger than that for a kid is
eight or nine it literally can blow
their head right off their body and
these kids are sitting there in blood
and gore and like a nightmare come to
life
and at noon the first 911 call up was
released to us yesterday by
the police
at least reading the transcript of it
and the kids saying we're in this room
room 111
and at that moment there's 19 police
officers in the hall and they wait for
40 plus minutes while hearing gunshots
go off so more kids were killed while
they waited outside so it's separate
that that's a distinct issue that should
be discussed because it's the worst
police work we've ever seen
yes in a shooting in the modern history
of if ever because i just don't know if
it's ever been documented before that's
one thing the second is obviously
dealing with
easy access to weapons of war that the
kid bought legally like he didn't steal
the gun he bought it legally the two of
eight hours days after his 18th birthday
with the intention of doing this he
waited the kid just waited till he could
legally buy it showing if if the waiting
period was still 21 years old in that
state like is in some others today and
buy an ar this probably doesn't happen
because the kid didn't want he wanted to
make it easy to get the gun yeah and he
wait till he's 18.
so there are two different distinct
issues here and we talk about
i think it's fair to talk about both but
to come back to the bigger issue always
which is
the fact that the gop has put
easy access to guns over the lives of
our children and that's literally what
we're seeing
yeah and and you know
you know and that is the
like that's the sick thing is that
it doesn't
like even ted cruz today i don't know if
you heard me before but he came out and
said you know we need to go to church
more and you know and well you know
bannon got
there was a shooting 2017 as a church in
texas they were slaughtered there so all
we have to do is harden every place
there's been shootings schools
supermarkets churches synagogues mosques
shopping mall outside inside just hard
at everything you know as opposed to
dealing with the issue which is
look we can't go backwards in time
there's over 300 million guns out in
america but we can make it harder for
the next shooting to happen that's the
best we can do is look forward
yeah
yeah i know and and and ah
and then they have this like nra
convention and they ban
guns perfect why oh because it's safer
that way yeah
it's such a hypocrite dean it's like
amazing to me
greg abbott don't forget signed into law
all his
texas being a second amendment sanctuary
state sure and then they have the
audacity now to go like this is just
it's the same pattern dean it's like i'm
not even shocked
taker is going to come out blame video
games
never take blame he's going to say that
it doesn't work if they had gun
legislation why did it work in australia
then why right look we just lifted the
age to 21 about buying an ar-15 the
shooter in buffalo was 18 and illegally
got his gun and this shooter legally got
his gun so right off the bat that's a
simple one change it up to 21 years old
that's for starters but there's
you know what you also with greg abbott
in texas is cutting millions maybe
hundreds of millions of dollars i've
heard in mental health funding so to
help people in the they talk about
mental health they won't find any way to
help people with mental health issues
they won't
they'll never address any issue they had
a machine in 2017 at a church there in
uh southland or sutherland in texas
all thoughts and prayers
look there's no god that's going to
listen to thoughts and prayers of people
who made these mass shootings possible
if you believe in god and if you do you
believe in the god i believe in which is
a compassionate god a caring god
if you're gonna send prayers there after
you help kill 19 children that god's not
going to listen to you i wish there was
a vengeful god i'm not the old testament
type of god person but if there was an
old testament type of god there'd be a
few people i have on the list i'd be
like god these are the people you might
want to help us with right now yes
yes and uh
and you know and thank you christy
0117 from twitch why
and i'll ask you dean it's a good
question why can you buy an ar-15 even
the inventor said it was never intended
for
civilian use so why why well president
biden in his speech last week after the
last mass shooting made a great point
and and even this week he followed up on
it apparently the profit margin with
ar15s is great so from gun manufacturers
they make more money on that than a
handgun
exactly so it comes down to nra is a gun
manufacturer's lobby that's all it's
about it's about selling guns so
from 1994 to 2004 there's a 10-year ban
in ar15s and you people can google the
studies at first they weren't sure did
it have an impact later studies now i
talked about on my show northwestern
health and others that are not political
at all have said the ban did reduce the
number of mass shootings during that
period when compared to afterwards no
doubt and the fact they capped capacity
magazines at 10. so you couldn't sell a
high-capacity magazine of more than 10
bullets they said that they've had even
bigger influence so it saves lives it's
not going to end gun violence in the
country it's going to reduce the loss of
life and the same people who claim to be
pro-life could give a [ __ ] when people
die of gun violence because they're not
pro-life they're selfish they are self
they won't wear a mask they didn't care
if you died of kobe they don't want to
ban ar-15s they don't give your children
die in school you know this is the world
we live in right now that's my article
right there look at that
yes everybody i want everyone to
check out the great dino badala's new
article in on msnbc.com we need more
than new gun laws we need a new supreme
court james madison's notes from the
1789 constitutional convention make no
mention of a right to own a gun for
self-defense or recreation everybody
read dean's article and we're going to
know
if you're if you're on twitter i tweet
it out at dinobiddle if you're on
facebook facebook.com dean of radio
it's there or just go to msnbc.com it's
there because it's a new i just went up
a few hours ago my here's the first
thing i want people to understand we
keep hearing
second amendment constitution to have a
gun just so it's clear that's not true
that's a fabrication that is a political
point not a legal point i said there's a
lawyer let me read everyone the second
amendment here it says a well-regulated
militia being necessary for the security
of a free state
comma the right of the people to keep
and bear arms comma shall not be
infringed
it was very clear when they drafted the
second amendment it was about states
having to be able to form a militia one
was that there were some people who were
states rights people and they they
feared the federal government others
have shown that there was a compromise
james madison drafted this but slave
owners in virginia who are delegates
patrick henry
and
uh patrick henry and another one whose
name just escapes me right now why i
can't i don't know why anything uh
george
okay anyway there's two big delegates
from virginia one was patrick henry give
me liberty or give me a death guy he
owned a lot of slaves so for his slaves
they didn't get liberty they were afraid
that the north if there were slave
uprisings and there were at the time
would not send their troops down to put
down slave uprisings so they said
we need to make sure that we have a
guaranteed right to have guns so we can
put down slave uprisings that is so much
of the origin the second amendment which
is talked about a little bit now there's
a great book by carol anderson professor
carol anderson going through the true
history of the second amendment that's
not something that could be taught in
schools today because the critical race
theory ban because it might make some
white parents uncomfortable to learn
about the real history of the second
amendment but getting to my bigger point
from 1789 from the beginning of our
constitution to 2008 no federal court
ever said the second amendment said you
had a personal constitutional right to
own a gun outside of being in a militia
nobody said it but in 2008 the supreme
court in a 5-4 decision with justice
scalia and the five conservatives said
for the first time in the history of
this nation suddenly now they've
fabricated this you have a
constitutional right to have a gun
that's in the case dc versus heller the
result of dc versus heller is it struck
down state and local laws across the
country since then trying to save
people's lives from guns because now the
other lower courts are stuck by the say
well the supreme court said you have a
guaranteed constitutional right to have
a gun and while there are some
limitations
we're going to err on the side of giving
you access to a gun in fact last week
john the ninth circuit court of appeals
in california considering a california
law two-to-one decision the two trump
judges struck down california's law that
bans
18 19 and 20 years old from buying
semi-automatic weapons and they go nope
dc versus heller says that's not fair
it's a constitutional right again just
to be clear
in the debate of the constitution
in the notes of james madison who
drafted the second amendment never ever
talked about a personal right they
literally made this up the second
amendment does not say you have an
individual right to have a gun again
before 2008 no federal court ever said
that so are you hold on i really because
this is intriguing to me and i don't
want to i don't want to go so quickly
past this
i think it's an important point for
people for us to think differently than
we've been taught by the the media but
really the right-wing media you have a
constitutional right to have a gun
there's nowhere in the constitution and
let me add one other thing
as i wrote my new article
the first amendment says congress will
make no law respecting an establishment
of religion or prohibiting the free
exercise up that was creates
the right to religion like freedom of
religion
and the next law the next amendment if
they wanted to say you had a
constitutional right to have a gun they
would have said congress shall make no
law prohibiting the right of the people
to keep and bear arms they didn't do
that it's the same people were at the
first amendment then the second
amendment they say a well-regulated
militia
being necessary for the security of a
free state the right of the people to
keep the bear arms shall not be
infringed they would have just said
congress shall make no law
so what was that
hold on dean this is what i mean
so what were they saying with the whole
well-regulated uh militia they wanted
because in the debate of the
constitution in 1789 there were
delegates in the south were fearful that
the federal government would have a
standing army and impose their will on
them so they're like no no we need to
guarantee that we can raise our own
militia in our state virginia militia
south carolina to protect us in case the
federal government becomes so
overbearing and they want to come down
and take our rights that was part of it
so that's why it says a well-regulated
militia being necessary for the security
of a free state capital s state their
state that's about one state
meaning our so new york we can have our
militia we have a guaranteed right
to have a weapon if we're in that
militia this is clearly what the second
amendment was about but
in my article i said to a great article
in 2014 in politico how for 25 years
behind the scenes the gop and the nra
started saying no no no let's say the
second amendment gives you an individual
right to have a gun so hit think tanks
and these scholarly papers saying this
they literally fabricated folks and
finally in 2008 they had five right-wing
just justices on the court who finally
agreed with it so again everyone said
let me ask you a question no federal
court ever said you have a personal
constitutional right to have a gun it
was invented in 2008 and we have to
overturn dc we have to overturn heller
the way they want to overturn roe v wade
if you want to save lives from gun
violence we have to start rallying
around overturning heller heller is an
abomination it is not a legal decision
it is a political statement that has now
resulted in more americans being dead
period it is killing americans heller
has to be overturned to save lives so
let me now play devil's advocate sure
oh river edgerton for the 10 bucks okay
let me okay uh keep those super chats
coming dean and i gotta make a living uh
i don't want any money john every time i
come on there's money flowing he's
making it rain while i'm on here yeah
sorry
so let me ask you just i'm gonna play
devil's advocate please do let's say the
proud boys say well
we want our state of virginia we want to
create our militia where we have ar-15s
can't they get away with that verbiage
and and and say that is what the second
amendment is
is telling them to do it says here a
well-regulated militia
that is involved with the state so
if the state of virginia if their
legislature were to vote that we have a
new militia today and it's the proud
boys you know what you're going to have
a pretty good argument but they're going
to be a state militia not a roving you
know bunch of people just do whatever
they want here's the thing the irony in
all this of course is that the supreme
court's about to strike down roe v wade
yes saying it should be state by state
in each state you should choose your
abortion laws right but when it comes to
guns
dc versus heller says we can't do that
state by state so and you might go well
that's inconsistent because it's not a
legal decision again it is a political
decision by the supreme court
overturning roe v wade is a political
decision just like over heller decision
was saying there's a second amendment
right because the result is that states
cannot regulate guns the way they want
in new york we can't ban guns
now
pre-dc versus heller we would have we
could be able to ban guns across the
state we could have done that we could
have made that argument now we can't so
now we can regulate them and also to
remind people the ar-15 ban from 1994 to
2004
that
predates dc versus heller i don't know
if a federal ban on ar-15s will actually
be upheld this supreme court might
strike it down going it violates heller
which is you have a consultation right
to have a gun this is where we are now
we're in a new world and we don't pay
attention on the left often to the
supreme court and their decisions except
for ones that we like this is really bad
we have to rally around overturning
heller we really have to rally around
reforming the supreme court because this
is absolutely [ __ ] the 6-3 court for
the rest of our lives john the right
right-wing will control the supreme
court that's outrageous the stench of
donald trump will
will continue and continue
until we either you know
expand the supreme court
make dc and puerto rico a state right or
you know or and the filibuster and those
i think
those are the three key things aren't
they dean it's that or we form our new
country where it's just the california
new york new jersey
connecticut vermont i imagine
illinois
and we keep our tax dollars because
i'll tell you when roe gets overturned
and the fact that my federal tax dollars
are going to go to states to help
oppress women and rob them of their
fundamental rights i have a real problem
with that and i think others as well and
i think we're going to get to a point
where people are going to say
i i cannot my religious faith does not
allow me to oppress women so i want my
religious liberty to ensure my tax
dollars do not go to red states in
anything they're doing to enforce their
bans on abortion to prosecute
doctors and women they're going to come
for women look what they did in
in oklahoma this week they're banning
abortion at fertilization which means if
you're a woman in
oklahoma at conception your uterus
becomes property of the state of
oklahoma you literally have lost control
of your uterus the minute on day one of
the conception they own it because if
you do anything you're going to go to
jail this would also mean that they
would ban the um
they have to pill to them
oh my god what are you john they're
turning it into the red states want to
become like
a bible theme park but by law like they
really want the bible the bible has come
to life but it's not the real bible the
gops made up their own religion people
kind of think that there's nothing
talk to experts talk to fuel zhang john
people saying there's nothing in that
the bible which says life begins at
conception they go it's here if you read
this and you hold it up to a mirror and
the sun hits the right angle it's like
rage is the lost ark it's like a scowl
you got to have a pole and a hidden city
like no it's not there they made it up
to control women and they're imposing
their religion as the law of the land
and their religion is about saving lives
but they absolutely refuse to do
anything to save lives from gun violence
so they don't care about anything but
power and control this is a very
dangerous republican party we've never
they've never been this emboldened this
is who they've been but now they're
actually passing laws
to match their rhetoric which is the
most alarming part of where we're living
right now well yeah and i think that
trump appealed to what was already there
it wasn't like it wasn't there right
it's just he made it okay to be a racist
and to be a sexist you know
it wasn't like
it wasn't like they're like we love
muslims and trump's like we're going to
ban him they're like oh okay no they
hated muslims for years they were
marinating the anti-muslim rhetoric for
years by the right the same thing this
white nationalism i saw a poll now 60 of
trump supporters believe in the great
replacement theory of course they do
because
in their lives thinking things have not
worked out as they've dreamed and for
most of us our lives not worked out
exactly as we dreamed we're doing a you
know a podcast at three in the afternoon
on a saturday come on
noon but i enjoyed it
but i don't blame i'm very happy to be
here i'm kidding about that i'm like but
we generally don't blame people of color
for our lives not working out the way it
has no they do and that's why the
traction of white victimhood which turns
into great replacement theory and even
fears going forward that they're going
to be somehow
replaced and you know maybe in
retrospect us on the left talking about
demographic change a lot of time being a
good thing
it kind of fueled their fears it wasn't
like
you know they made this up on the left
people like well demographic change is
coming it's going to change everything
and i was deep down and wondered is that
at some point going to
cause a reaction on the right and sure
enough it has demographic changes is
real we didn't make it i haven't had it
i haven't had any children so i've not
even contributed to demographic change
but it's coming and
it's i don't know how they're going to
deal with it but we saw in buffalo with
an 18 year old kid
dealt with it by shooting black and
killing black people
and it's very alarming that the kid's 18
he's got his whole life ahead of him but
he believes somehow
the best days of white people are behind
him and he's going to go kill
eight people eight black people or 10 or
12 like dylan roof in 2015 in south
carolina to start a race war i mean
their goal was to start a race war yeah
why people come up and exterminate black
and brown people that's that's really
their goal so that the white people can
assert their
in inherent right to be the masters of
our domain of america that's what's
going on i don't know where that goes
john i don't know that turns into
malicious roving bands or bands of
white terrorist groups going around the
country
trying to shoot people of color or not
because i know there'll be a reaction to
that i know people of color are not
gonna we have the same second amendment
right if you want to say
that as they do and i hope we never get
to that but some of them want that some
of them are hoping for that and it's
really dangerous to see this it's not a
civil war by state lines
it's a race war that they want now more
than anything
yeah uh mark hurley is from ireland
thanks for the 10 bucks
as a non-american i have a simple
question why can't the president call a
national
referendum on guns put a new amendment
into the
constitution
mark
thank you welcome to our country what
country are you living because we might
be going there
he's in ireland he's in ireland it's a
pretty good country hey look i'm half
italian half palestinian you know it's
i've never
seriously had more conversation with
friends who have explored can they get
another passport or dual citizenship if
they're eligible for it because their
grandparents or parents come from
another country because they're fearful
of where we're going he can't put we
don't have set up a procedure for
national referendum it's state by state
to amend the constitution it's laid out
in the constitution you can have a
constitutional convention with the
states or you could have congress passed
by two-thirds which will essentially be
a referendum but for congress a
resolution and then two-thirds of the
states have to pass it it's a very long
tedious process
the last constitutional amendment
escapes me now
the er era did not pass that was the
closest
um
but in the
60s and 70s we may have had one in the
70s i'm pretty sure about voting rights
changing the until 18 years eight year
old you can vote
but it's a long process in the world we
live in today i don't see
on anything even things we agree on you
know john
you've got now even people on the right
agree take big money out of politics we
should be able to overturn citizens
united by passing a constitutional
amendment but it can't happen because
the people in power will not allow that
happen all right let me play you this
idiot for a second dean can't get dumber
i don't think it's possible
and of course
when 911 happened we didn't ban planes
we secured the cockpit and of course
leave it to barack obama to make this
issue more divisive instead of allowing
the nation to come together mourn and
heal well when 9 11 happened we didn't
ban planes we secured the cockpit and of
course exactly
sure so there's yeah right
right there's a limit number of planes
in the sky it's easy to secure the
cockpit
for all the gun shootings around the
country we would literally have to
secure every place there's been a mass
shooting which is supermarkets churches
theme parks um
schools shopping malls schools it's not
just schools are you gonna say and when
they say schools they're telling you
they don't care that black people were
assassinated the week before because
they didn't call for
making supermarkets safer because they
didn't care when black people died i
have to be honest the right is the gop
is a white nationalist fascist movement
and i mean fascists literally
technically they've embraced violence
january 6 they've surrounded they
celebrate donald trump who gave us that
terrorist attack we're dealing with the
white nationalist fascists who want to
turn their religion to the law of the
land
and this is who we are we got two major
parties one of them is a fascist
theocratic
look look dean i agree with anita blake
did she say obama
i was trying to figure but i guess it's
impossible to figure out what the [ __ ]
she's talking about well he's black and
they just went to the fox news audience
like yeah that's right the black man
shouldn't speak
anymore it is white tv it is clan
must-see clan tv with tucker klansman
and the rest of them over there
unbelievable dude
what else is going on what else we got
my friend well
the what we what do we do what do you
want us to do what do you think would
save lives john first of all
ar-15s should be banned i agree 100
and not just ar-15s any assault weapon
all assault weapons should be banned
any mag over
what 10 bullets 10 is what we had for 10
years it worked
banned
anything above it banned now then you
have to go through a mental check before
you can get you know they got to go into
your past they got to see [ __ ] that you
tweeted out that you know
do a real thorough check before that
person gets a gun
look if i'm in my house and i want to
protect my house
fine i can get a handgun right of course
no one's going to stop you
but
if
you know if i need an ar-15 to shoot a
burglar
with 33-round mags then i don't deserve
to have a gun
you're going to shoot everyone you're
going to shoot people sleeping in the
next room with that because it goes
right through the velocity of an ar-15
is so far the bullet so much greater
than a handgun that's why
the exit wound
when you see doctors talk about the way
a bullet a normal bullet from like a
handgun if it hits a bone sometimes the
bone will actually deflect the bullet ar
bullet because the velocity will go
right through it in fact it'll pulverize
it it'll kick around it'll destroy
tissue in ways you've never seen like a
war
scene it will if it hits an organ it
will actually almost vaporize the organ
that's what the bullet the speed of it
that's why it's so deadly that guy had a
handgun
still children probably
similar death toll but maybe a little
less adult certainly much less i don't
know because i don't know if you heard
the gore details those kids were shot up
so bad they were unidentifiable right
they use dna but the ar that's what the
ar does the ar just so people understand
this sounds gruesome it can cut you in
half if you're your child that literally
can cut you in half because that's the
bullet speed you're dealing with and you
shoot a bunch of times in a row so these
children could have been literally
decapitated their bodies cut in half and
they kept shooting and 19 cops stayed
outside well
nine-year-olds are saying please send in
the police
and
it's two issues in one
if you would ban ar-15s maybe the guy
gets a handgun maybe he does something
else
maybe he gets help
background checks have to be expanded
right now john under federal law there's
only two reasons you can't get a handgun
right now you have a crim a felony
conviction or you've been
institutionalized you have to be
institute legal literally
institutionalized that's the only
prohibition there are certain states
with red flag laws now we need a
national run where if someone's able to
buy a gun legally and show some of scary
behavior they can take the gun away the
person go to court make a showing that
i'm fine but they have to be examined we
need that absolutely there's no way
around it the background check has to be
much more
severe there needs to be a day a waiting
period yep you know there's another part
we don't talk about there's about a
hundred people in america every day who
lose their lives involving a gun 30 are
murdered 60 suicides or two-thirds of
suicides
and waiting periods in certain states
where they have three-day waiting
periods has brought down the suicide
rate by gun because people feel
desperate make the wait three days and
often things will change for the better
you hope or they'll get help we need a
national waiting period for guns as well
that'll bring down the number of people
who die by suicide but we need a federal
approach not you can't have state by
state you can't have this patchwork guns
are transportable you can buy them in
indiana easily and go to chicago and
commit a crime with it that's why 60 of
the guns
involved in crimes per the police are
from neighboring states namely indiana
where has lax gun laws they're not
buying in a state like illinois with
very severe with strict gun laws they're
just not doing that
so this to where we live in there are
there are solutions to save lives but
i'm telling you overturning dc versus
heller
which is called overturn heller heller's
gotta go to save live i wanna save lives
overturn heller
and it's a key decision because we can
pass some great laws and then right-wing
courts can overturn it inciting heller
but you know
here's another thing bozobort says and
you know i don't even know why i even
have to hear him speak it's like the
same reason i don't know why i have to
hear freaking donald trump speak and
i'll get to that that's because the
media yeah yeah i'll get to that dumb
ass next but
bozo bert goes um
oh i love this you know because now
they're considering
training teachers into being you know
into handling you know
uh pistols to defend classrooms you know
a teacher doesn't
enter that occupation to become a part
of a militia
i mean what
she needed
you know
john 19 police officers who were trained
to do that
coward in fear in the hall and it's
understandable because that guy had a
weapon of war but they're police and
they have to go in that's why you become
a police officer
i had numerous teachers call my show in
the last few days saying i didn't become
a teacher to become a sheriff i became a
teacher to teach children yes
that i know nothing about guns now
you're suddenly going to teach me
everything i need to do about a gun and
their fear is shooting a student because
the cops didn't want to go in
the guy is an ar he's shooting at you
everything's happening fast so you're
just going to shoot wildly to save your
own life shooting other children maybe
you shoot the guy if you're lucky shoot
yourself
they don't want to do it but that's not
the answer that's that's a talking point
of the gun manufacturers to sell more
guns it's not
a way to save lives saving lives is you
can have more security guards at the
school you want to use taxpayer money
for that but look look at the gop
they're banning books they're betting
black history they're blanding
transgender teens they're banning saying
the word gay but they won't ban the
actual thing killing students which are
guns it tells you they care about
nothing they care literally they're a
soulless party
that to me is it's irredeemable as the
way it is now
we need to have we can only our only
goal is to defeat them politically so
badly that maybe they regroup as a party
but i don't see it i think we're stuck
with them just getting more and more
extreme
but just to get back into the teaching
thing dean right like
could you imagine i mean look
i never got a gun because i had children
you know i've tried i never wanted
an accident to happen which you know
happens all the time sure you know i
don't want a kid a friend of my kids get
a hold of the gun somehow you know it
doesn't matter today in america two
children die by unintentional gunfire by
accident every day on average every
single day
yes so
so
why would a teacher want to be like
have to bring a gun home every single
day you know and and if they have
children have to worry about it all the
time
you know like yeah they'll have the
geometry book and have a gun like a
glock on top of it like all right make
my day kids who didn't study for the
test it's not going to be at some point
one teacher said to me her fear is what
are the students getting mad at her and
one of them takes the gun from her you
know what happens then and just yeah
normal course of kids being
outrageous or thinking it's funny
and you've got a gun in every classroom
you know and no offense i've i've had
frail
like 75 year old
teachers i mean you know
you know i can't
i can't see you know gun-toting grandma
you know being able to like
you know handle a gun i have an idea how
about this john why don't we assign one
republican
uh elected official to every school with
a gun to protect our children how about
that how to have lauren bourbon on
a couple hours a day in colorado where
she's from she is she loves guns she
should be on patrol every day you
protect our kids you know what let's see
them actually do something he's supposed
to talk about the [ __ ] because they
want nra contributions they don't care
about kids because children don't make
donations to their campaigns the nra
does that's the reality
yeah and now getting to donald trump who
i don't
you know like
you know i i got to the you know i had
yeah i got to lax
like at 12 30 this morning
so i was just living the life where do
you go john just traveling the country
of the world yeah i was in florida so
so i you know so i get in and then like
as soon as i get out of the flyaway bus
get in my car
first thing i freaking hear on the radio
when i turn it on donald trump saying
more dumb [ __ ] at another one of his
rallies he was at the nra convention
yeah but
at what point
do we
i mean look i mean
george bush
disappeared pretty much from
you know
after he left obama's pretty much
has gone away unless it's like a certain
incident
but yet we got this fat pile of [ __ ]
every single day entering my freaking
airwaves and i'm damn freaking tired of
the team donald trump should not be
speaking at the nra convention donald
trump should be preparing for lunch in
the prison mess hall that's where he
should be now it's 500 in about 10 days
since the january 6 terrorist attack
that was all trump and he's still not
been charged he might get charged in
georgia i am more hopeful in georgia
than any player yeah i've had people say
that on the show the man should go to
prison because there's no pardon that
can save him it's state law violations
the d.a down there is not playing games
he's not made political statements it's
just doing the work has a grand jury and
panel right now they began investigating
starting earlier this month and i'm
telling you brad raffesburger the
secretary of state who's a key witness
now that he won the primary over donald
trump's gop candidate he's not going to
be afraid now he's getting subpoenaed
he's going to go to he said if he got
subpoenaed he'd testify now with his
race over and trump came after him
i think you might
there's a chance i don't want to get
people's hopes up that donald trump does
get indicted before these years out in
georgia then the trial would be sometime
next year while trump's a candidate for
president and if he's convicted he'll
put the appeals over off as as long as
he can
but he could still be
the republicans will still nominate him
even if he's indicted a felony so
they'll say it's just political bs what
about hunter biden what about hillary
clinton's emails what about blah blah
blah you fill in the blank
there's a chat look he spoke at the nra
convention this john it's so
unbelievable the nra is having a
convention three-hour driving distance
from where the 19 children are killed
and they're having a convention to
celebrate the very gun that murdered
these 19 children because they are
celebrating the ar-15 they celebrate
weapons at this convention this is
john if a muslim muslim if a muslim
organization
did like the nra and advocated policies
that resulted in americans being killed
every day
the gop would be calling for that muslim
organization to label a terrorist group
in shutting them down and stopping their
funding but the nra is literally
knowingly advocating policies which has
resulted in americans dying and the gop
celebrates them that's what we're
dealing with again i keep saying that's
what we're dealing with i know everyone
listening gets it but sometimes i have
to say it for my own sanity
yeah
no it really is sick and
you know
but that's
they don't give a [ __ ] dean like i mean
they don't care and they're gonna
go back to all they want this is to be
swept under the rug and then and then
and then get back into their [ __ ]
where they're going to protect you with
the gun you know they're going to save
your second amendment and then people
are going to buy this horse [ __ ] and
then another shooting is going to happen
do you know there's one shooting every
day now
there's that mass shootings
we're averaging right now because it's
in my article 10
every week so we're actually at 1.1
or 1.2 shoot mass shootings every day
and that's four or more people being
shot that's where we are because i just
wrote about it in my article
literally
1.2 mass shootings every single day in
our country this cannot be
acceptable you know when last time when
i was
very i became overcome by emotion
and it was really hard to do part of the
show i had to go to a break i was
actually happy afterwards because it
shows i'm not numb
to this because if you become numb to
these shootings of children and mass
shootings the other side wins they want
you to be coming up they want you to
check out they want you to think you
can't make a difference on this issue
because human nature is if you can't
make a difference you're not going to
keep
investing yourself in the issue like
we're never going to change it but we
have to believe we can change it we and
we could if we just elect two more
democratic senators
and hold the house we reform the
filibuster and we pass laws because
mansion and cinema oh no the filibuster
is more important than the lives of
children mansion and cinema to me are as
bad as the republicans at this point i
agree so if you're going to put
the filibuster over voting rights and
the filibuster over saving lives of
children and parents and loved ones from
gun violence look you're not a democrat
you're whatever you are it's not even
about party labels anymore you're just
selfish like a republican
but you know i you know i listed on the
last show i did
just how many
of these right-wing like politicians
like ted cruz and all these guys
they get millions of dollars in
donations from the nra so in other words
i just gandy they only care about their
wallets they don't care about a child's
heartbeat the only time they care about
a child's heartbeat when it's in the
womb that's the only time they give a
[ __ ]
you know the idea of we are pro-life we
care about the sanctity of life but we
will block
not just they won't support efforts to
save lives from gun violence they will
actively block that
the same thing like covered we learned
during covet everyone who didn't know
the right doesn't care about lives
because they try to undermine covert
protocols safeguards to save people's
lives we're seeing now with gun violence
they've been doing this for years so
yeah they they will ban they will ban
women from controlling their bodies but
they won't ban a guy from buying an
ar-15 there are so many ways to save
lives that are simple expanding
background checks we can't even get that
done on the federal level so you've got
25 to 40 percent they say of gun sales
with no background check at all because
they're private sales and there's no
requirements you got that you've got
these bad apple gun dealers where a
disproportionate amount of gun dealers
their guns are involved in crimes we
can't stop that we ship a federal law we
should have a much more strict federal
law on gun trafficking
we don't have that we don't have a ban
in ar-15s we don't have a federal law on
red flags we don't have a federal law on
storage mandating the way you store your
weapon which will save lives and
accidental discharge which kills
children in the house there's a list of
laws we can go through which is
supported by
anywhere from 90 percent to at least 60
percent of americans and we can't get it
through because we don't live in a true
democratic republic anymore
we live in a a state where it's it's
tyranny minority it's tyranny of the
minority i mean the minority rules us
right now and this is the world we live
in
and some of it has been this is where
the gop has been heading citizens united
making money just
legal corruption going on they're
gerrymandering his made state
representatives not have to listen to
the people they make their districts all
safe they control everything the the
rigging of elections through voter
suppression laws
we've lost democracy
the question is can we get it back i'm
not sure i don't really know if we can
get it back
we have to
have a long look the gop is about
long-term plans we're not we're very
immediate we have to start doing more
long-term planning and maybe it won't
solve things in two years john or four
or eight or ten
but look they're about to overturn roe
it's 50 years in the works they got the
heller decision that they wanted that
was in the works for 30 or 40 years we
have to lay the seeds for the next
generation it might not even benefit you
or me john but maybe your children will
benefit we have to think long term
sunflower dragon says thanks for the
five bucks number one cause of child
death in america is guns that's what
congressman swalwell said on this show
no
yeah it's just it was auto it was auto
accidents up until 2020. there's a
really good article npr that's where i
saw it i'm sure it's been covered other
places on that showing the graph of how
automobiles got safer over time
and guns are not and that brings me to
something else as a lawyer and it's not
talked about by democrats in 2005 the
gop control congress and gop president
george w bush signed a law giving
immunity to gun manufacturers so as a
result they cannot be sued civilly if
someone uses a gun and kills people i
can tell you as a lawyer the real world
result is that you have no incentive to
make your products safer and you go well
it's a gun how do you make it safer
there is technology the event there's
smart gun technology where a chip could
be in for two decades they've had it
where someone steals your gun no one
they can't shoot it well guess what gun
manufacturers have no incentive to do
that because they can't be sued so
democrats should talk about
overturn uh repealing
the immunity for gun manufacturers so
that in this shooting all these families
could sue smith and wesson and the
others and i don't care if they bankrupt
them i could give a [ __ ] you know sue
them to make their products safer just
like you do for cars and forklifts and
any other product it's called products
liability lawsuits they're the only
industry
look what we did with cigarettes look
how it changed the tobacco industry
these lawsuits is what changed it yes
they've given themselves immunity so
that couldn't happen to them because
they knew the people would be upset
so we need to repeal the 2005 law that
gives immunity to gun manufacturers
because it's absolutely [ __ ] it was
bought and paid for by the gun lobby and
the gop under george w bush gave it to
them again another thing that's killing
people that's killing people i've been
saying like since i saw
the movie skyfall why can't guns have a
fingerprint uh you know two decades
we've had technology we've had it for
technology for two decades to do that
and they don't
why not why not use it
it's because they look if they were
getting sued they would do it because a
defense in a products liability lawsuit
is that you've done everything you can
based on today's technology
state-of-the-art to make your product
safer and you can't make it any safer
the same way for a knife if i go a knife
cut my finger well a knife's got to have
utility right so it's gotta but they've
done all they can to make it safer it's
not like the whole thing's a knife
there's a handle that's plastic it's
secure
for the guns they have no incentive to
make their products safer at all because
of the 2005 law these are little things
that can be done like it could be done
now if manchin and cinnamon would agree
to get rid of the filibuster repeal that
law expose gun manufacturers to
liability and if they've done nothing
wrong they won't pay any judgments but
like tobacco companies it will result in
huge judgments and it will result and
like the opioid the pharmaceutical
companies now with the opioid
manufacturers it'll result in changing
corporate conduct and the product will
become safer so guns will come with
like the smart technology is one thing
might be more secure safeties on the
weapon maybe some companies go we're not
going to sell the ar-15 anymore because
we're getting sued all the time so it's
not safe any longer so we're going to
get rid of the ar-15 as a
a weapon in our arsenal of products
there you go the free market has an
impact on what we see sold
now i know this sounds crazy but i gotta
ask i gotta ask you something sure
could the families
of
uh uh uvalde sue
abbott
and you know for allowing these guns to
be purchased
you could sue that you can steal anybody
you want folks i mean the reality is you
could to win i i don't know what the
cause of action would be and there's
immunity for government officials acting
within the capacity of their work as a
government official if they out act
outside of the scope like if greg abbott
goes over and punches you in the face if
you can sue greg abbott that's not part
of being governor that's part of just
greg abbott thinking he's a tough guy
and
it'll be kind of weird because greg
abbott you have to wheel him up to you
and then punch you in the face so it's
gonna it's unlikely it's gonna happen
right now why is this guy bringing greg
abbott up to me he's like and gregor
said can you lean down and he'd punch
you in the face you're gonna be able to
sue greg abbott so that's not going to
happen
the it's more there'll be lawsuits
against the city
and the police department massive
lawsuits that are going to happen there
oh yeah yeah and we don't know that's
going to happen but why not sue the
manufacturer of the ar-15 that because
they can say we don't want our weapons
sold to anyone
under 21. they could say we don't want
our guns sold to anyone who's posted
things on facebook or twitter they could
do that but they have no incentive to do
any of that because they have immunity
given to them by the republicans in
2005. that is such a huge impact on the
actual product we're seeing sold it's
never talked about i don't know why
democrats don't talk about it non-stop
because it should make people's blood
boil that the republican congress was so
owned by the nra and gun manufacturers
they gave them something they've given
to no other company no other men no
other industry
civil liability from lawsuits from their
products hurting and killing people
unfreaking believable do you think that
o'rourke has a chance of unseating habit
i hope so i mean that you know beto ran
a great campaign ted cruz was less liked
than abbott even among republicans so he
got it really close but between now and
november who knows what what other
things issues evolve
come up or rise in that state maybe
people have it enough maybe they want to
change the state is evolving too
demographically and that's my last
question for you because i know you got
to take off what do you got going on
today dean
my in life i'm going to do my comedy
thing here at five o'clock here in new
york to a spot but i'm around on twitter
memorial day weekend or not i'm around
on twitter at dino vidalia or drop me an
email
dean dean of radio.com and by the way
for the first week of june siriusxm free
it's free for anybody if you've got a
radio you haven't used it in years turn
it on every channel is for free on
siriusxm for that so listen to my show
that's what i'm getting at channel 127
progress 6 to 9 pm eastern time monday
to friday so check out my show check out
the free music it's all free for a week
from now on siriusxm so i hope people
will check out my show if they haven't
and my mom loves uh this mom is the
greatest
mom's the best she's the best melendez
team but here's my last question before
you go sure
what's your
prediction in the midterms
look we're
162 63 days away because i counted down
on my show every day i can't remember
where we're at it's around there
look the polls right now are challenging
but
i'm not trying to make people have false
hope but i will tell you this it's up to
us if we win and what i mean by that is
when we come out big we win we outnumber
them we came out big in 2017 in the
governor's race in virginia new jersey
we flip those seats 2018 they were
worked up they had donald trump in
office we came out big we won 40 house
seats in 2020 we came out big we
defeated donald trump so 2021 democrats
didn't come out big in virginia and we
lost virginia
it's that simple if we come out big like
we did in 2018 there are more of us than
them and we can win i think there's
going to be surprises on the senate
level the house is going to be really
tight because we only have a five seat
advantage and they've redistricted but
don't give up hope because in 2020 we
lost 14 house seats which is so we
already lost 14 seats
so
it's not going to be as easy for them as
they think and democrats are raising a
lot of money which is a really good sign
it shows people have not given up
so i think on senate we have a chance to
add two seats i think in the house it's
going to be really close if you live in
a swing district
get out there get your friends if you
live in a in a really blue district and
volunteer for groups like indivisible or
move on where you can make phone calls
to swing districts in your state or
other states but
when we come out big we win big remember
that so when you hear these pundits say
democrats are going to suffer horribly
turn the channel they're idiots this is
a very unique year we have gop extremism
off the charts we had a january 6
terrorist attack by the republican party
people have not forgotten and the
congressional generic poll john
at this point in 2018 democrats had a
seven point lead which was showing we're
in great shape right now republicans
have a two-point lead with showing well
people might not be loving biden overall
they're not hating him and they're not
taking on democrats basis gop is being
scary and extremist we got to make the
case how extreme they are and something
like this with this massacre and they
won't they're just blocking any effort
to save lives of children in school you
think you're going to win suburban moms
by exposing their children to more gun
violence you're not going to do that
they're going to come to us so i think
we might support we might like muhammad
ali said we might shock the world we're
going to shock the world i hope so dean
and dean thanks again for coming on
thanks everyone thanks john fans you're
the best fans you really are my fans are
the best i don't really have fans i have
a family you've got a family our family
of supporters are out there they give us
hope you you inspire all of us and the
nice comments here in the comments
inspire me too when they say i'm needy
so i'm the needy muslim guy
so that's i can't help it
all right thanks so much man thanks
brother nice to see you all right i'll
see you the great dino badala
uh on the show and uh there's baby yoda
thanks for the two bucks always nice on
super chat saturday i'm just waiting for
my next guest to come on
and in the meantime i will be uh
well
i'll pay the bills if you will
uh as they say in uh radio terror
uh righty
here we go
our partners at betonline.ag continue to
be the number one source for all your
betting needs and sports info find all
the latest odds nudes and sports
developments including this year's
basketball playoffs major league
baseball scores fights and even next
season's nfl futures but online dot ag
is your continued source for all your
sports wagering needs including live
betting and of course
your favorite vegas casino and poker
games
it's really easy to get started so head
to the website today or use your mobile
device to sign up
uh and use promo code
clns50 that's clns50
to receive your 50 welcome bonus on your
first deposit
bet online dot ag
where the game starts
and uh now uh
let me bring in uh
one of my new favorite guests uh gabe
sanchez on the show today
hey how you doing
good how are you doing brother not bad
not bad
so gabe uh you know i just got done
talking to dean obadala are you familiar
with dean
uh no i'm not not too familiar no
all right well uh thank you lauren ibsen
for the four bucks super sticker on
super chat saturday everything helps no
we were just talking about this
this freaking
crazy ass massacre
that happened and i gotta say gabe like
you know
it
it's not shocking that the gqp ain't
gonna do [ __ ] about it again and all
they do is come out lauren bulbert wants
to arm teachers right you know ted cruz
said you gotta go to church more
give me a [ __ ] break yeah you've got
people like marjory taylor green the day
that the shooting happened you know keep
in mind that like the buffalo mass
shooting that happened at the
supermarket was on may 14th this other
one that happened in uvalde was may 24th
we couldn't even go 10 days without a
mass shooting mass shooting happening
every single day yep but you've got
marjory taylor green who decides you
know what we don't need gun control
actually what we need is
more god i mean that's literally what
she tweeted that day and then you've got
ted cruz who's talking about you can
only go through one door
then you've got people like ken paxton
who says we gotta arm them
which is ridiculous because here's the
thing
there's actual studies out there one
specifically that talks about how
arming people in a school actually
governs by fear
and there were more uh the likelihood of
death to the death toll to increase was
actually greater when guns were
introduced into the school from armed
security guards whatever you want to you
know consider them
so
throwing guns on a situation to say like
well if there's more guns and it will be
more protected actually that's proven to
be
totally debunked and that isn't true at
all
so yeah you've got republicans and i
think it's so
insane to now tell
someone who goes to school to become a
teacher
because they want to
do
something good for society and teach
children
now has to be learn how to
shoot a gun to protect those come on
yeah it is it is insane like as if a as
if a teacher's job wasn't already hard
enough right you know let's say you go
through school you get your degree then
you're like doing you know let's say
teach for america because you're saying
i really love teaching and i want to
give back
and i want to and i want to bring some
sort of change especially in some of
these areas like texas and florida where
you might have leaders who want to take
away things they want to ban books they
want to you know cancel certain aspects
of education so teachers might say you
know what this is the only impact i can
really make on these children so that
they can actually be decent human beings
and not try to follow some
fascist dictator or a crazy government
and
you have that
that ability to take someone who has
decided to take a job that is already
difficult you're dealing with
15 20 30 kids maybe depending on the
class size that are varying in age who
are
at different levels of development
they're distracted they can't stay
focused some are some aren't
and then you say
you know what we're gonna give you a
nine millimeter keep it in your desk so
if anything goes poorly and you just
wanna kind of
defend yourself
it's right there i mean imagine what a
teacher would have to go through if
let's say one of their students from
either present or past comes into the
hallway to shoot up a school
and they have to be the person that
actually shoots that kid
right they have to they have to take
that toll not even cops want to shoot
people right
like we just learned right exactly you
the cops that were in uvalde you find
out that they decided they would go in
but they were only going to go in to
save their own children
like the selfish mentality that you are
as a cop like i get it like i'm not a
parent but i would imagine if i was a
parent you're going to do whatever you
can to make sure that your child is safe
however you also took an oath and a duty
to protect and serve those in your
community and so if you're now going to
say actually i'm not going to save
everyone i'm only going to make sure
that my kid gets out of that classroom
i also have this fear that
the reason they've changed their story i
think the number is 12 times they
changed the timeline 12 different times
yeah which is insane yeah insane i know
right
so i think
and and i hope i'm wrong
that at one point when somebody went
into the school or something happened
between where there was a gap in time
that they have not talked about
that a cop did something and may have
made the situation worse
they might have gone in maybe they shot
someone maybe they uh instigated
something i don't know but
i have this fear in the back of my mind
that
the reason they've been so reluctant to
actually reveal details or the reason it
keeps changing like well actually the
timeline was this or the guy didn't
enter here or it was actually this door
you know as ev every time it keeps
changing i i do kind of begin to believe
that
maybe somebody [ __ ] up and now they're
trying to cover up for it it just smells
the whole thing smells yeah to me oh no
they know that yeah they know they
didn't go in i mean that's a fact i mean
they
because that did you see that freaking i
don't know if he
he wasn't the sheriff but he was the guy
speaking and
he had this this mouth thing going on
did you see that guy there was the one i
saw the one guy who kind of shut down
the questions not yesterday but the day
before when they're like can you give us
more info and he's like no i can't
basically he just shut down the reporter
i think there was stuff on msnbc and
some other
uh affiliates that were kind of rejected
any sort of answer to their question and
then yesterday there was like there was
the
sheriff or i forget what his position
was but that's when they were trying to
blame um
uh the the teacher they're trying to
blame the teacher who propped open the
door to go get their cell phone out of
their car and then make it seem like
well the shooter wouldn't have gotten
into the school if the door wasn't
propped open because of the teacher
going to get their phone like we're
really gonna now scapegoat and say it
was the teacher and not the gun
right like you've got people like marco
rubio who say well listen if uh if we
take if we ban guns these murderous
people are just gonna find another way
to murder people
i i would not expect someone to kill as
many people if they're slinging a blade
or throwing a hatchet or shooting an
arrow right like the the amount of
impact that you can make with a
automatic rifle or a semi-automatic
rifle
and mow down children
is far greater than you trying to sling
out some bow and arrow
to kill someone
yeah so when i hear people that that
make the argument that it's like oh well
these murderous people are murderous and
they're going to find a way to murder
and it's like no you dumb [ __ ] that's
not at all how it works
no
no
it's it's
it's amazing to me like it's just
freaking amazing
they're so
they're so afraid of whatever this and
it's not a large percentage this small
percentage of people
that
are so into the guns that we need the
guns it's not every american that that
has this you know [ __ ] tiny penis
that needs a gun to hold exactly
you know it's not everybody
i mean you you look at the data and uh a
recent poll from 2019 was indicating
that 94 there have been other polls over
the years from 2017 to 19 12 19
and they varied from like around 80 mid
80 percent to 92 percent 94 was the
latest one which also in the study they
found out that people actually supported
having safe abortions available mind you
so again you've got another situation
where a minority a small group of people
who are insecure
and very sensitive want to control the
majority of people in the country and
what they want to do and going against
their own best interests so when you've
got these people who
uh want to go against what 94
of americans support which is universal
background checks for gun purchases
that's the bare minimum like the bare
minimum you know and then the other
thing too is like you've got these
republicans who want to scapegoat mental
health as well which is insane
because republicans have done nothing to
support anything in terms of health care
or services or any sort of government
assistance in terms of saying hey you
need therapy or you need medication or
or this or that you've got them saying
actually under the trump administration
we're going to
roll back an obama era regulation that
would make it easier for mentally ill
people to get guns so if it's really a
problem then why are you allowing this
to happen especially when you guys
control
the the party and you have the say when
your leader
is in office you're going to let that
happen but now it's a problem
it's [ __ ] it's just
it's just freaking
insanity it's just insanity
i don't know how it's like you know like
i can't remember the congressman but he
was saying like
like i mean how many you know what are
we doing do you ever see that
oh chris murphy i think it was through
your time yeah yeah on the it was that
day it was on the floor and he's like
what are we doing what what is the
purpose of us being here if we're not
going to help people
yeah and that's that is the that is the
that is the banner that is the
republican party
[ __ ] you
not me
right it's all about they don't care
about anyone they they don't they
probably don't even care about their own
family members if i had to be honest
like i guarantee that these people are
so rotten to their core whether they
were that way before they got into
office or the party has transformed them
into this rotten kind of bean
but they don't care healthcare baby
formula gasoline prices gun control none
of it
they don't give a [ __ ]
nope
nope but then they have the audacity to
say we're the pro-life movement we want
to save the children yeah and you're
like
you have the ability you have the
control and the power to make a huge
impact on the lives of your constituents
and what do you do you [ __ ] the bed and
you take money from lobbyists so get the
[ __ ] out of here with that like don't
come into here and try to say like oh
we're high and mighty and we think we
should do this and protect our people
well if that was the case then you could
have done that years ago
it's you know i was watching cnn
yesterday with scott the engineer and i
saw this guy
and he was talking like this and he come
down with his mouth and he was saying
well they were barricaded and they so
the cops didn't go in and he kept going
it was it was i
i couldn't watch them and i've been
trying to find it as you were talking i
can't find a freaking guy was it the
main press conference that they did
during the there was there was there was
one press conference i saw in the
morning
which was the one where they tried to
blame t a teacher for letting the
student no no no this is where he admits
that the cops didn't go in because
the procedure is if they were barricaded
they didn't want to you know you know
and so he goes so he's asked he's got
the questions like this and then
finally they asked for the fbi guy to
come in so when african-american fbi
guys you know that was that was the
press conference that was the one where
they tried to that was the one where
they went over the timeline and they
blamed the door being propped open on
the teacher that was that one because i
know who you're talking about because he
said i'm gonna bring in the fbi agent
and then he came in yeah and he had the
whole like classrooms all written out on
the chart right exactly yeah yeah what
the hell was going on with that dude man
he
did you notice his mouth has gone like
this the whole time yeah i don't i don't
know i i'm gonna say that like i've seen
some stuff written about that uh
the uvalde police and i've been told and
i've seen
that
they are well one one is they're
incompetent but i also have read about
how they've made other situations worse
like the community itself
is good
but it's the police in that community
that have given in a bad name
and i just saw i don't know if this is
official but i think it is there was a a
press release that came out
like just bef i just saw it before i got
onto the show
um
from the uvalde police
and they said
uh basically our entire you know they
have this whole long release which i can
i can send to you but they said our
entire department is thankful for the
offers did not sustain any
life-threatening injuries
well of course not because they were all
[ __ ] cowering outside yep being the
good guys with the gun
yep
so you know you've got
also i want to point out that they've
got multiple agencies
that had to come in
and now they're calling even more
agencies to come in and help the
investigation honestly for me i would
say fbi handled the situation because
uvalde police are clearly
tainting this investigation
right yes like
and just like ah shorty once says is
alex jones gonna claim this is all fake
too probably he did well here's the
thing i you know i sat through about an
hour of uh his show that night how do
you do that jesus i know well i was i
saw a clip that somebody shared so i
decided to to listen in and
one the people that call into that show
were [ __ ]
batshit crazy like one guy
you know he he called out the
republicans to say you know the
republicans will just say
uh we got to arm more teachers and we
got to give more guns and that's not a
problem and then he's like democrats
will come in and they'll be all high and
mighty and try to play the high moral
ground and this and that and try to ask
for gun control and he had a problem
with that but he's like at the end of
the day the real problem is big pharma
big pharma is the reason like what was
this person on but alex jones that night
was also one of the people like candace
owens that was spreading the photo of
the the trans teen
in saying that it was ramos instead
and so everyone started sharing this
thing and then the the next day the kid
had to go online and be like i am still
alive
the date is may whatever
uh may 25th i'm not dead i'm not the
shooter
but ever everyone had spread around this
pho these photos actually is saying that
that was the shooter and this per they
were like trans and they're a leftist
and they were going against you know
coming back for payback or whatever it
was
because they were indoctrinated and they
finally saw you know they finally were
woke or whatever it was and so alex
jones and him and then uh ted nugent
came on and they were talking about it
was just it was a [ __ ] show of of
right-wing nut job personalities trying
to push the false flag
uh narrative
speaking of uh
right wing nut jobs here gabe i'll give
you this one to play for you
uh i guess ted cruz
got confronted did you hear about this
oh yeah by uh benjamin i think is his
name yeah let's see i haven't seen it
yet but you know
uh let's see how i can get uh
oh it's not gonna be the greatest i
think once you once you play you can hit
the the full right now
okay you ready
okay hold on
all right one
two three
go
we're good
yeah we got it
is
[Music]
waited until the day
that no you know that but you stand here
you stand at that you stand at the nra
convention it is harder it is harder
when there are more guns
why did
why when 19 children died 19 children
died
as on your hand that is on your hand
right through that wonder
wow wow so i see some people that were
asking what were they saying and so
basically he you know went in for a
photo as a as a as an attempt to get in
close to ted cruz obviously it was a
video
so he was yeah and so the questions he
was asking was you know like how would
you a lot like why did you allow us to
happen like what are you gonna do about
it you're not doing anything you have
the audacity to basically go to the nra
convention speak there
yeah and not do anything and he's like
well i had a good uh i had a good answer
for how we can handle i have a i have a
good proposal which by the way ted cruz
has been proposing this bill that would
uh actually do gun reform and actually
uh uh
push down gun violence which is [ __ ]
which is complete [ __ ] it's all
fanfare it doesn't do anything yeah he's
gonna go in and try to push his
narrative like i've got the answer well
clearly ted cruz wants to only put one
door in a building which is
outside the fact that it's a clear
violation of [ __ ] a fire code hazard
yeah like nothing's ever gone wrong when
only one door was uh available for uh
entry and exit like yeah nothing will
ever go wrong with that idea but ted
cruz is
such a pathetic
cuck that he would not
like the the guy
uh you know tried to ban dildos the guy
wouldn't defend his wife when trump uh
uh
you know insulted her this is a guy that
won't even stand up for his own wife
yeah what makes you think he's gonna
stand up for anyone else he scapegoated
his daughters and blamed them by saying
they were the reason i went to i went to
cancun i was just being a good father
guys just being a good father just being
a good father and it's like the guy that
will
uh what will [ __ ] on his own children
and let them take the blame because
they're the reason is an awful person
the guy that will also abandon his dog
snowflake ironically named and leave it
at the house while he goes to cancun is
a horrible human being yeah this is the
person that is he is one of the faces of
the republican party and in a clear
poison that is ruining the well that is
the american democracy
there's another there's another video uh
that some people brought up which is the
reporter from skynet news uh right yeah
with skynet news uh that
what happened
is where they confronted him i think it
was the the 25th of the 26th they were
asking him questions about what they
could do about what's going on and he
was like the media and the you know you
guys the democrats the media have your
own narrative and you're pushing your
own ideas um
i can i can get the link for you in a
second i can send it to you yeah
but that's the that has clear audio and
it's the the reporters are just not
letting down they just keep asking they
keep asking and he you know is skittish
and he's like well yeah and then you
know leaves and you know obviously lucky
there was a door that he'd go out of
i am and i would i have no you got it
okay hold on let me just get it all
gotta you know this is a little process
let me like in the meantime let me just
say bob carmody this is exactly what
a friend of mine was saying
thanks for the five bucks i say we need
to publicly show the photos of the
carnage it worked for selma
yes and that's what my friend was saying
if they see and i look i
first of all i wouldn't you know like i
wouldn't you know i would not want to
look at it anyway but if they see the
how just how badly these kids were shot
up right
i think it might change you know
i mean the fact the fact that there
there's a there's a story of a child
and i think they did an interview with
the child who had to take the blood
from one of their classmates
and rub it on their body
to make it seem like they had been shot
and they were dead so they wouldn't be
shot from the gunman
like this is not something that a
nine-year-old
yeah this is not something a
nine-year-old should have to go through
this is the type of strategy you would
do when you're in a [ __ ] war zone
which unfortunately the classroom in
america has become the war zone like
anywhere you walk now but specifically
in these classrooms they become the war
zone whether it's political and they're
trying to ban stuff or whether it's guns
coming in and threatening lives
but the fact that a nine-year-old had to
one
in the moment had to think oh [ __ ] i
gotta protect myself like i can only
imagine what was going through their
mind at that time but the fact that they
grabbed blood and was like oh okay this
is how i need to cover up and make sure
that i don't die is
if i were a kid in that situation i
would 100 not have even thought of that
if i was going to i would be so
traumatic and adrenaline running and i
would probably be crying my ass off
but i would not have the i would not
have the idea to do that which is insane
to be like that's an idea that the kid
had because that's what they had to do
to survive that's the world that is the
reality that we live in now
where not only that
but we've also assumed a responsibility
on a random person to say hey you have
to risk your own life to save someone
else's life
it it's it's it's insane like the
republicans that's the world that they
want to live in and i think you know the
comment brings up a good point you know
tony and i were talking about this
yesterday on the show is we should 100
show these photos and show the actual
graphic carnage that is that is done by
these weapons right the collateral
damage right
and you you
you look at what happened
and it made me remind uh myself back to
or remember back to when i was getting
my driver's license and i was in
driver's ed and you have to look at
photos or videos of like oh there's a
car accident this person was torn up
they didn't wear their seatbelt they
were drunk driving whatever it was and
you remember and you're like oh [ __ ] i
i do not want to be that person i do not
want that to happen to me like you've
got europe right europe puts
puts the effects of smoking on
cigarettes right we don't have that in
america we have a you know a surgeon
general warning but in europe they've
got photos of like this is what happened
to your lungs if you smoke this is what
will happen to you you know
so i think it there is a definite it's
it's shock you know it's
shock porn if you want to call it that
but also it is effective right seeing
something that gruesome
would be like i i don't want that to
happen to me
and look yeah
didn't the cigarette companies eat you
know i talked about that they would
actually put like
all your lungs like pictures of your
lungs yes and so they haven't in the us
we don't have that but in europe they
are like okay we you know we obviously
can't ban these cigarettes but the
agreement is that you have to advertise
the side effects
of what smoking can do to you right the
long-term effects what will be the the
damage that your body will uh will deal
with
if you're smoking and especially smoking
for a long period of time you know like
what happens
um
but
we don't do that in america and the only
time i ever see something that's done
graphically is at least with driver's ed
where they're trying to show you don't
do this and don't do that so that you
won't end up like this person which is
dead yep
um
dede thanks be for becoming a youtube
member
i appreciate it you know um
before i play ted cruz though like uh
there was something on uh
what's the there was like a young
african-american
person that my friend was kept on
telling me
terrell something and it
happened years ago
and they finally his parents allowed to
see
like you know uh the images of him being
of him being lynched or something i
forget what the
oh wow no i don't i don't know who that
is but
but it changed everyone's
like you know as soon as are you talking
about are you talking about emmett till
emmett till that's it yeah yeah yeah
okay
yeah yeah many many years ago but still
ineffective you know playing everybody
um gabe thanks because he was trying to
tell me about it i i couldn't look at
the picture i took a glance
explain to everybody what happened yeah
so emmett till is a is a a black kid
from us i think 14.
um
it was in
i'm trying to remember it was in chicago
or if that's where it happened but
basically a 14 year old kid and the
story goes
uh he he cat called a woman
and it was a white woman
and uh yeah i was in chicago and uh he
he cat called the white woman and then
the woman said
he was trying to rape me
and then uh he was dragged he was
murdered he was lynched
um and done publicly through the streets
right and so
then you find out also years later
that i think it was on the woman's death
bed the the white woman who said this
guy tried to rape me emmett till
turns out that she was lying
and she revealed this on her deathbed
before she before she passed away
so i mean the other crazy thing is that
so yes it is graphic so they had an open
casket you know to show
uh
what happened right they were not going
to hide it the mother insisted on a
public funeral so that people could see
people could know that this wasn't just
like a an urban legend or or
you know um a made-up story she wanted
people to know that this is what people
deal with especially if you're black
and so it wasn't until this year which
by the way was like end of march when we
passed the emmett till anti-lynching act
which is insane
that that wasn't illegal
until this year yeah right yeah and then
you've got people who are like well you
know it is what it is and uh i mean it
you know people get in trouble it's like
we
we went so long until 2022 to finally
say okay guys enough's enough
no more lynching
that's a hate crime that's a federal
hate crime
like
how that was not passed earlier
obviously because of you know
certain representatives probably want to
you know with the good old boys want to
keep that old thing uh intact
but
those are the people those are the same
people that don't want to control gun or
that that don't want to limit guns they
want permit less carry those are the
same people that want to control a
woman's body and tell you that you have
to have a child those are the same
people that want to give a teacher a gun
and when that when the teacher is
unfortunately
uh you know
shot because they don't know how to
handle them they're not proper training
that's a traumatic event that you're
putting on someone and saying okay now
shoot
then they're gonna say okay well you
know what the kids the kids in the
classroom should really arm themselves
right ar15 over the shoulder ready to go
put on a hard helmet and a flak jacket i
mean they already sell bulletproof uh
backpacks
like we live in a world where we have to
sell
and give kids bulletproof backpacks
like how [ __ ] insane is that
where
where you have to
go to a store and say okay well i wanted
to get this jansport
but i also know that there's a
possibility that my child might be shot
in a school
by a by a you know an armed gunman
yeah
just like leslie ramsey said
thanks for five bucks this insanity
needs to stop and the only way that we
can make it stop is turn out in droves
on the midterms and it's so damn
important that's why i know you guys are
on the minus touches you know
and i know those guys are gonna go like
crazy
oh supporting all those candidates
because it's
this is it folks
this is it
you know i mean i mean
everybody should do everything that they
can
you know i do this show
you do your shows
how does his dean
i mean we could all do this but we all
have to do something everyone's got to
play their part man right you know what
i'm saying
yeah i mean that's the thing like we
have to we cannot we can no longer rely
on the representatives to do their job
when we have uh a small group of people
controlling
the greater number of people the
majority when you have a minority
controlling a majority
we've got a problem here right for the
same people that are like
you know trying to tell you that you
should go you know dismiss the eight
extra million people that voted for
biden over trump right these people live
in a re uh like just their own fantasy
world
where you can have a president like
trump who loses the popular vote in 2016
and still
becomes president like you have a
minority of people that's the mindset
it's
all about me
not about we you know yep and
you've got these people who
who again you know they represent a
minority it's white
male
you know very sensitive i will mind you
like add that to it uh trying to control
what the majority of people the
overwhelming majority of people want
right
you shouldn't have to walk out of your
door and out of your house and and just
think to yourself well today might be
the day i get shot or today that might
be the day that uh this right is taken
away from me today might be the day that
i
don't come home i'm not able to kiss my
children i'm not able to see my wife or
my partner or my dog or whatever it
might be like
if you leave your house thinking well i
don't know today's you know anything can
happen right like
that's the world that we live in now
unfortunately and in order to stop that
and and move forward instead of
backwards
in these policies and rules and laws
is to come out in 2022 and vote right in
la uh i think early voting just happened
just started today i saw the polling
place around my corner just opened up
you know in other states like if you're
in that lake
i'm in l.a yeah how the hell just go
hook up with tony when he's in missouri
ah you know it all happened through uh
through tick tock and uh and twitter uh
he found me and was like i'm a big fan
of your stuff uh you want to come on the
show i'll interview you we can talk
about it and then from there
we just started continue to collaborate
and then i came on as producers
i'm over uh in los feliz area oh you're
pretty close to me oh nice hell we'll
grab a beer one of these days all right
let's hear off
ted the [ __ ] i haven't seen this yet
like i hadn't seen the other one but i
always try and
you know like even when i do the show
i'll like scan the internet i mean i
think like so much so but i'll look for
something that just happened you know
what i mean
but this you say is old right or it
happened two days ago this happened i
think on the 25th or the 26th
okay i just gotta i just gotta meet my
mic
it's the parents
there are 19 sets of parents
who who are never going to get to kiss
their child tonight
again
then do something to reform gun laws you
know it's it's easy to go to politics
but it's important it's at the heart of
the issue i i get that that's where the
media likes to go it's not it's where
many of the people we've talked to here
like to go the proposals from democrats
in the media
when some violent
psychopath murders people a violent
psychopath who's able to get a weapon so
easily 18 year old with two
ar-15s if you want to stop
violent crime
the proposals the democrats have none of
them would have stopped this
this guy i swear to god
i i i would love i wish he was a boxer
so i couldn't get an arrangement or and
beat the living [ __ ] out of them first
of all yeah the democrats oh their
legislation really stricter background
checks that ain't gonna do anything
banning assault weapons that ain't gonna
do anything you [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's
like i said ted cruz is a pathetic cuck
like he will sit there like there was
when when beto came in and confronted
abbott during their you know nra press
conference that they do anytime there's
a [ __ ] shooting the nra is there okay
they are there providing the narrative
and giving them the messaging and saying
you gotta hit bullet point one two three
you cannot talk about four five six
as long as you do that you'll get your
check and then we'll see in a couple
days for the convention okay
but these people
like ted cruz
are complete cucks to the lobbyists that
are the nra and other people that have
you know not america's best interest
right you they keep pushing the whole
good guy with the gun could stop a bad
guy with the gun
bull [ __ ] [ __ ] it has been disproven
again and again and again and we
literally saw it in real time
on the 24th and then we see we keep
seeing it in real time as their keep
[ __ ] they keep [ __ ] the bed because
they keep revealing details about how
the cops didn't do anything they waited
90 minutes they went in to go get their
kids before the gunman was taken down i
loved i love what jody says
the guy who read green eggs and ham on
oh yeah
this party is full of political stunts
mark b thanks i am gonna play the whole
clip i just i just i just had to stop it
because i was so freaking pissed about
hearing his [ __ ] narrative saying
that
the democrats
things that they're proposing isn't
gonna work which is a load of horseshit
and it drives me nuts so i like to
dissect the brick
and so yeah you've got you've got stuff
like i was bringing up like the betto
interrupting uh
abbott
when they get more pissed off at you
interrupting their nra press conference
kind of uh
um pr stunt yeah that should tell you
something when they get more pissed off
that you interrupted them
talking about the shooting
then the actual shooting itself
that is
incredibly revealing to the people that
are making the rules and the laws of
this country and the people that are not
protecting your children the people
that are abandoning you like ted cruz
did
when he went to cancun yep
he said like mommy piece of [ __ ] yeah
i'll play more at a clip hold on
why does this only happen in your
country i really think that's what many
people around the world just
they cannot fathom why only in america
why is this american exceptionalism so
awful
you know i'm sorry you think american
exceptionalism is awful i think this
aspect i think this aspect
you get your political agenda no it's us
god love you senator it's not i just
want to understand why you do not think
that guns are the problem why is this
just an american problem
it is just an american problem sir mr
cruz why is america the only country
that faces this kind of you know what
now but you can't answer that you can't
answer that can you say you can't answer
that why is this why is it that people
come from all over the world to america
because it's the freest most prosperous
safest country
and it may be the free maybe the most
what a dick man oh what a dick like the
the audacity to tell someone
and say
i'm sorry you feel that way hey you know
look look uh yeah it really sucks
but um
we're not going to do anything about it
so go [ __ ] yourself like that's what
he's saying right and especially like i
think the line that that really hits the
most is like why is this only
a problem in your country yes
like why why have you guys not solved
this yet everyone else has figured it
out whether it was scotland or australia
they figured it out yeah and they
dropped the suicide rate they dropped
the they dropped shootings gun violence
rate
so clearly there seems to be something
that works like when clinton signed the
94 bill 94 i think it was uh
where he said we're gonna ban assault
rifles
right
that worked it worked yep and then when
it was uh you know when it expired it
was like 200 and some odd percent that
gun violence increased because 43 243
it's yeah 243 which
is insane
like these numbers don't add up right
yeah they add up in all the wrong ways
when you're telling the deaths and
you're telling the gun violence and
you're saying well listen when we when
we took it away it actually made things
better
common sense when we made it available
again [ __ ] hit the fan and it was
terrible yep and it still is but yet
republicans you know
are willing to be quiet as long as those
dollar bills keep getting stuffed into
their mouth
and
was that at the nra convention oh no
no no that was a at a i think it might
have been at the high school or nearby
it was the day after the the shooting
the pre the the nra convention was
yesterday and today
which of course there always seems to be
one
right around the corner and i don't know
if it's there is just a high frequency
of nra conventions
or what have you but
never does the nra ever decide whenever
a shooting happens and they have one
that's like very close in time frame
like i don't know less than a week they
never say
maybe this is a little insensitive maybe
we shouldn't hold this thing right now
maybe the best thing to do is like
take our own advice and kind of
talk about what should be done thoughts
and prayers but no you're like actually
what we're going to do is we're going to
double down on this we're going to have
people like trump and ted cruz come in
and talk and then not only we're going
to have trump
trump come in and talk we're going to
have trump say the names
of the 19 children and the two adults
who were killed
at the shooting and then ring this
very ominous bell like it's some sort
somewhere like dystopian
future that we're in
like it was very
it was disgusting to watch it was very
cringe
it was
something that i was like i never
thought i would actually see something
like this that was the type of thing
that you would see in like a futuristic
film where like a dictator or someone is
like naming out the names of the people
that have wronged them and making them a
public display and ringing a bell to be
like don't be like them
that is the vibe that i was getting from
that convention it was very dark and
very ominous
try a group a group that's trying to
control us that's what it is you know
uh
who's news let's see what he has to say
here
no
uh where is he like you can look if
people want to you can go to
opensecrets.org
i believe it's a.org and you can look at
all the contributions that come from the
nra and it i mean it shouldn't surprise
anyone when you look at the top 20
people you know you've got ted cruz and
you've got corn in and you've got uh
you know others on the list that are
there as a representatives who should be
doing what's the what is the best for
society and those in their constituents
is instead
taking money
and going the opposite direction
whose news says the nra contributed over
440 000 to ted cruz's contract
i think he means campaign right trump jr
poses as a big game hunter
trump jr is an [ __ ] i mean i i did
that guy is like a coked out freaking
loon oh yeah
but they're all just
despicable and
damn it i'll tell you gabe
donald trump brought out all these
freaking ass wipes
out from hiding you know oh no trump no
out of the woodwork and now they feel
it's okay to be a dick
i mean
the fact the the sad fact
of like the reality we live in is trump
he let the boogeyman out he made this
behavior okay whether it was him
you know talking up [ __ ] at a at a rally
where he was telling people to go beat
someone else's ass
you know telling people that they should
you know do whatever they can to defend
they should fight like hell you know
it's like why do you think
crime rates and violence increased not
only across the country during the time
that president trump was in office
but also
at the cities and towns that he went to
go have a rally at those areas also
spiked in violence around the same
period i didn't know that that [ __ ]
idiot showed up to give his
wannabe dictator
fascists kind of speech like the guy
wherever the guy goes
he brings [ __ ] he just wipes out and
has collateral damage
like this the event i mean like not only
that but then you've got you know
there when these events happen a lot of
people think like
it's only the victims that died right
there's the family members too right
that are like very sad and obviously
recovering traumatic an event that
happened and but everyone wants to say
oh it's just the you know just the
people that die that those are the real
victims no it's not you've got other
people like for instance i think his
name is joe garcia who had a heart
attack
his wife was killed
in the shooting he had a heart attack
the next day and now they left behind
four kids like nobody ever talks about
these other stories of people who are
impacted with these long-term effects
like what happens to those kids are they
wards of the state texas clearly doesn't
want to care for them you know like do
they be you know i don't know where they
go do they have all their family these
are all questions that like have to come
in and
come into question they need to be
answered
but the republican party they don't care
they don't give
two [ __ ] shits about what happens
they're like oh thoughts and prayers for
the victims that died but everyone
else can [ __ ] go take a hike like
i'm so the lack of empathy is is gross
i'm so sick of the thoughts and praise
yeah okay
okay let's
you know let's feign
uh sympathy but do nothing i mean give
me a break with that crap
and and keep in mind gabe it was ted
cruz on top of the freaking car hood
going we will not go silently in the
night as he was riling people up to
freaking
you know start their insurrection ted
cruz is a [ __ ] [ __ ] he i mean like
yes ted cruz is 100 you know he is up
there in terms of [ __ ] from the
republican party yeah you know it it is
very much you you bring up a good point
right you've got someone like ted cruz
who you know a day or two days or
whatever it was before the insurrection
goes on a car tries to have his macho
man movement and he's like we will not
go silently into the night
you know like we gotta defend this
country we gotta fight like hell you
know he's pushing this narrative which
was the big lie
and it also is revealing how quickly
those people are like i never said that
dude i never i was never there i never
said that i don't know where you got
that idea even though there's a video of
me that's not that's not real which is
another side effect of the trump era
which is also a product of hitler i
don't know if many people know the
history of like how hitler you know
when his his his time into his ruling
but like one of the things was to
uh to shut down any news outlets or
anyone talking anything about him so
that he was the only
what that was garble's uh exactly yeah
he was the same one who also wanted to
burn books and you know limit the
circulation of information and they
wanted to shut it down
right i know exactly it's crazy how
these things happen in cycles you know
we're having our moment too
and the midterms like you brought up you
got to go out and vote because that is
our moment to define if we are going to
be [ __ ]
because 2024 is also right around the
corner and that is even more at stake
beyond 2022 so it's not just the
midterms now but it's the general
election of 2024. and you know what gabe
if i could just change subject for a
second i mean
i mean would you have wanted trump in
office
during the ukraine conflict with russia
right now not at all i mean i mean
like
i just thought of it when you said 2024
at least we got someone
who's level-headed
you know who's
who's unified
europe and everybody
even switzerland
into joining and donating
you know
their weapons their food everything to
the ukraine taking in their immigrants
right
do you think that would have happened
under trump no not at all trump would
have easily said uh yeah let's just
follow putin he said it's there so it's
theirs guys can we just like move on to
something else now like that is that is
exactly what trump would have done yeah
right for the same reason that we you
know we don't know the conversations
they had
right we oh like you know can you tell
us what happened behind closed doors
nope not going to tell you what we
talked about oh the transcripts not
going to give them away yep they're
missing
like this is the person that we would
want to control like obviously
republicans and the [ __ ]
red hat maga people want to say this is
our leader and this is the guy you know
we're not in a cult but we [ __ ] wear
everything that has his name on it we've
got his face on our [ __ ] underwear
like
we are groping anything that has trump's
name or affiliated with it
these are the people that wanted trump
to be president again these are the
people that wanted trump to lead us
right the guy couldn't even take
responsibility and ownership of kovid to
say hey listen wear a mask distance
it's going to be a [ __ ]
hell to be through
but
we got to get through this together like
he couldn't even he could not even unify
the country on this and then of course
like we shouldn't be surprised that
you've got people that don't want to
believe even anything that's coming out
of the president's office right because
they're like fake news if i don't agree
with it then it isn't real it isn't true
like
the weird ass we need to like we need to
[ __ ] get out of the simulation
because whatever this matrix matrix
problem that we have right now is
[ __ ] messed up and broken
and someone needs to unplug and get out
because like right now
the the reality we live in is so like
every time you you wake up every day
you're like
what's gonna happen today
can it get any worse and then somehow
somehow a republican does something and
is revealed
by some rules some laws something they
said that you're like oh okay well
i guess we'll go
gabe you're exactly right because every
time i book a congressman to come on or
a congresswoman
they always say okay you know what are
the topics because i always book them
like
two or three weeks out like you know
what i mean and then and i go well
these are some but
you know
you know just give it on any given day
yeah the republican party's gonna say or
do some dumb [ __ ] that's gonna come to
the forefront that we'll talk about and
and without fail it happens every single
day i mean like so tony and i on the
show we got this this bit uh this kind
of segment that we do on fridays that i
was like we gotta you know we gotta do
these like mini kind of things that we
can play with and we have this show
that's called uh bonehead of the week
right and so we have a poll that people
can vote on youtube and twitter and we
have three people that are running and
this week you know of course it was
people from texas it was abbott cruz and
uh and ken paxton
but every week we we have a poll and
we'll run it on thursdays because what
we realized is that we could start on
monday or tuesday
but by the very next day on wednesday
the [ __ ] has gone completely south and
somebody else has said something or a
video has been revealed or whatever and
you're like [ __ ] like we should have put
that person in and even on thursdays by
the end of the day someone has revealed
themselves to potentially be a bonehead
so we have two other categories which is
a dishonorable mention and an alpha cuck
for those people who can be slotted in
at the last moment that do something say
something
you know
whatever it might be so
just to your point like things things
can change within a day within hours
but uh for our little segment that we do
you know i've got i've got the assets
and i'm making the video on thursday
night or friday morning realizing that
like minutes before the show starts
something drops and i'm like oh no this
person just got booted and this person
has taken their spot instead like
you know
that i know the fact that it's every day
like every day every hour something
changes and the fact that we also just
live
with the expectation
that some new piece of [ __ ] is gonna hit
the fan and it's gonna be [ __ ]
stinkier and messier
i like i know
it's like all the freaking time
yeah gabe it has been a freaking
pleasure to have you on and i will say
that um
i'm gonna because i have to go to my
beer on the balcony yeah this is gonna
be a great one
because it's with my producer
both of my albums and has produced a
bunch of albums for a bunch of
you know like like a bunch of famous
people but it'll be an interesting break
from you know oh yeah so i mean we
always
yeah
so that's uh for all my patreon and
youtube members at patreon.com
stutteringjohn but there's the link if
you want to donate paypal dot me slash
john melendez inc i'm taking off this
week so
this this is the last interview i'll do
for my regular show until until next
saturday whoa
special
so
so uh uh thanks so much is there
anything that you want to plug yeah yeah
yeah actually i wanted to uh there was a
a troll of tony's after us being on the
show and he was going after uh tony's
hat so i just wanted to
put my own handle on the hat you know
uh
but yeah you can follow me uh at i am
gabe sanchez it's pretty simple just my
name um you can find tony nine our
podcast we do every single day monday
through friday 12 p.m to 2 p.m eastern
on saturdays we have the best of on
sundays we have bonehead of the week
recap that we did on friday
and then we'll also be doing the january
6th uh hearings we'll be live streaming
them for the
uh the sixth that happen throughout the
month of june starting on june 9th so
yeah check us out uh tony michaels
podcast on twitter and on youtube
give us a follow subscribe um
and have a great memorial day weekend
yeah same to you gabe thank you so much
buddy yeah see ya all right the great
gabe sanchez today i want to thank my
guest today dino bedala and uh gabe
sanchez uh
it wasn't easy i'd
well i'll tell you about it my beer in
the balcony but i i screwed up on on my
flight so i was supposed to fly out at 8
00 a.m on yesterday and like a schmuck i
uh
i thought it was 8 p.m
and i missed the flight
so i had to book another one and then i
had to fly at 9 30 or something so i
didn't get until really late so i'm
really glad that i got these guys on
today because uh you know it was very
hard a lot of people couldn't do it all
right i'm gonna go over to my beer in
the back and let me thank my moderators
today um
uh
uh nikki b who wasn't here but benny
loco and the newest
wrench holder um andrea brauer thank you
so much for um doing your best to keep
out the uh riffraff and i'm gonna go and
do the beer on the balcony i want to
thank my sponsorbedonline.ag
and i want to thank all of you for all
your great
super chats and paypal and everything
else all right this is stuttering john
saying yay